Sabe aquele café da manhã inocente?
Pãozinho, queijinho, cafezinho com
leite? E se eu te disser que esse como
pode estar abrindo pequenas frestas no
seu intestino, virando uma chave
inflamatória e bagunçando seus hormônios
ao longo do dia? Calma, não é drama.
Mais de 30% das pessoas têm dificuldade
de gerir lactose e o glúten, mesmo em
que não éíaco, pode aumentar
temporariamente a permeabilidade
intestinal. Já a caseína, proteína do
leite, em alguns perfis aciona sinais
inflamatórios no intestino. Hoje eu vou
te mostrar de forma simples e prática
como identificar se esse trio, glúten,
lactose e casina é o seu sabotador
oculto e o que fazer a partir de agora.
Fica comigo, deixa te situar como
história real de consultório, no
jeitinho como a gente gosta, gente como
a gente. A Ana, 34 anos, vivia com
barriga estofada. À tarde, cérebro
embotado depois do almoço e um sobe e
déce de energia que parecia montanha
russa. Trocaram o leite por sem lactose
e nada. Cortar o açúcar melhorou um
pouco. O pulo do gato veio quando
testamos duas coisas separado, pão de
manhã e laticínios. Pastou uma janela de
30 dias organizada para ela dizer:
"Doutor, parece que tiraram o algodão da
minha cabeça e não foi sorte, foi
método." Vamos por partes. O glúten é um
conjunto de proteínas do trigo, senteio
e cevada. A fração chamada gleadina
conversa com uma molécula do seu
intestino chamada zonulina. Pense nela
como o porteiro dos portões entre as
células da mucosa. Quando a zonuín
sobem, esses portões afrouxam, entra
mais coisa do que devia e seu sistema
imune fica em alerta. Em pessoas com
doença celíaca, esse processo é intenso
e crônico. E não celíacos pode ser
transitório, mas suficiente para gerar
sintomas em subgrupos suscetíveis.
Tradução: Nem todo mundo sofre com
glúten, mas quem sofre sofre de verdade.
E tem novidade boa. Um teste de sangue
recente mede a liberação de ter leucina
2 após a exposição glúten em tubo e
mostrou alta sensibilidade,
especificidade.
Promessa de diagnóstico mais fácil para
celos sem precisar voltar a comer glúten
por semanas. Isso muda o jogo para quem
sempre adção por medo de passar mal. Por
enquanto não tá disponível no Brasil,
pessoal. Então tem que ter paciência.
Agora, um detalhe que quase todo mundo
erra, lactose é um açúcar, caseína é uma
proteína. Problemas com lactose geram
fermentação, gás de extensão, diarreia,
porque faltou lactase para quebrar esse
açúcar. Isso é comum no mundo e atinge
mais de 1/3 dos atos nos Estados Unidos.
Só que trocar para leite sem lactosa não
resolve se o problema for a caseína. E
tem nuance da caseína que pouca gente
comenta, a variante A1, que é a
predominante comum no leite vaca
convencional, pode algumas pessoas
aumentar marcadoras inflamatórias
intestinais e piorar o desconforto,
enquanto o leite com beta caseina 2
parece provocar menos sintomas
indivíduos sensíveis. Não é modinha do
mercado. Ensaios clínicos duplo cego t
mostrado essas diferenças, tá, doutor? E
onde entram os hormônios nessa história?
Bora lá. Laticínios, especialmente o
leite, tendem a elevar os níveis
circulantes de GF1, um hormônio de
crescimento que conversa com vias
metabólicas e de proliferação celular. é
o chamado insulin growth factor. Não é
bem ou mal por definição, mas em pessoas
predispostas, esse empurrão no GF1 pode
ser a peça que faltava para explicar
oleosidade, acne, dificuldade de
controlar fome em certos horários ou
performance que despenca a tarde. É por
isso que na visão funcional a gente olha
alimento como sinal biológico, não só
como caloria. Há também um elo conhecido
entre gluten e tireoide. Pessoas com
doença celíaca tem risco maior de
doenças da tireoide, especialmente as
autoimunes. Se você tem tiroidite,
rachimoto e sintomas gastrointestinais,
ignorar o intestino é pedir para
patinar. Importante, nem todo
desconforto com trigo é por glúten. Em
muita gente com intestino irritável, os
frutanos, um tipo de fod map presente no
trigo, cebola e alho, são os verdadeiros
vilões do inchaço. Em estudos com
desafio alimentar controlado, frutanos
provocaram mais sintomas do que o
próprio glúten em pessoas que juravam
ter sensibilidade ao glúten. Ou seja, às
vezes você pode estar brigando com o
jogador errado. Como transformar tudo
isso em ação sem nó na cabeça? Passo a
passo do jeitinho que eu faço na
clínica. Primeiro, se você desconfia
fortemente doença celica, histórico
familiar, perda de peso sem explicação,
diarreia crônica ou anemia teimosa, você
pode cortar o glúten
ficar 30 dias sem consumir, mas converse
com seu médico sobre os testes corretos.
Se não há sinais de alarme, propõe a si
mesmo um experimento pessoal de 21 a 30
dias. Não é para virar refém da dieta, é
para gerar dados do seu corpo. Durante
esse período, tire o trio de frente,
trigo, glúten, leite derivados bobinos
comuns. Se precisar de lácteos, teste e
pequenas quantidades, opções com casina
A2, que será leite de cabra ou ovelha ou
determinados bovinos. E observe, lembre,
sem lactose não é a mesma coisa que sem
caseína. Evite cair na pegadinha dos
ultra processados sem glúten, tipo tem
rótulo bonito, farinha refinada do mesmo
jeito, por exemplo, farinha de arroz que
vai dar pico glicêmico e pode dar também
fome de rebote. Anote sono, energia,
gases, trânsito intestinal, pele e no
caso das mulheres o ciclo. Isso não é
frescura, é método. Depois reintroduza
de forma separada. No fim de semana
tranquilo, teste trigo puro, por
exemplo, pão de fermentação longa e
observe 48 a 72 horas. Em outro momento,
teste laticínios específicos. Seu corpo
vai entregar o veredito. Erros comuns
que sabotam teste. Achar que tirar só o
queijo resolve se você toma cappuccino
duas vezes por dia. Confundir melhora de
inflamação com efeito placebo e voltar
pro mesmo padrão na segunda-feira e
acreditar que se o seu amigo come pizza
sem sofrer, você também deveria
aguentar. Cada metabolismo é um CEP. Se
o seu intestino reclama, escute. E se
você quer um norte resumido para hoje
mesmo, troque café com leite com café
preto, chá a um latê de amêndoas ou
aveia sem açúcar por 30 dias para ver.
Faça o teste do pão por três a qu
semanas sem trigo e depois reintroduza
com método. Se melhorar muito, mantenha
o que funciona na maior parte da semana
e deixe sessões para eventos sociais uma
ou duas vezes por mês sem culpa.
Abordagem integrativa sem sofrimentos
excessivos. Moral da história, glúten
lactose e casina formma um trio que em
parte da população acende inflamação e
mexe em eixos hormonais. A boa notícia é
que com o experimento orientado em um
olhar de causa a tal visão funcional,
você descobre rapidamente se eles são
seus vilões ou apenas codantes.
Informação, teste e ajuste fino. É assim
que a gente tira o intestino do sufoco e
os hormônios agradecem. Saia do vídeo
agora. Se você gosta de ficar no
superficial, eu vou te contar uma
verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
conselho de medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens,
omitir protocolos controversos. Na
comunidade fechada não tem esse filtro.
Eu compartilho os exatos protocolos que
eu uso na minha clínica. Casos de
reversão que pareciam impossíveis,
combinações label que funcionam,
fornecedores confiáveis, interpretação
avançada de exames e basicamente ter
acesso ao meu cérebro médico sem
intermediários. Temos lives semanais
respondendo perguntas, PDF com 47
protocolos exclusivos e grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a visão funcional
real, sem simplificação para massas,
clique em seja membro. Não é para
curiosos, é para quem quer resultados.
M.